this episode is brought to you by tonal
t-o-n-a-l
i'm super excited about this one and i
was skeptical
of it in the beginning tonal quote tonal
is the world's most
intelligent home gym and personal
trainer end quote that's the tagline
from their website folks to give you the
one sentence summary and
this device it's really a system is
perfect for anyone looking to take their
home workouts to the next level or
someone who just wants to get maximum
bang for the buck
in a tiny tiny footprint of space
tonal is precision engineered to be the
world's most advanced strength studio
and personal trainer it uses
breakthrough technology of all different
types
to help get you stronger faster i was
introduced to tonal by three different
friends
all of them are tech savvy one of them
is a former competitive skier
who's doubled his strength in a number
of movements using tonal even though
he has a long athletic background
and i'll paint a picture for you by
eliminating traditional metal weights
dumbbells and barbells tonal can deliver
200 pounds of resistance which doesn't
sound like a lot but it's actually
it feels like a lot more at the high end
in a device smaller than a flat screen
tv and you can perform at least 150
different exercises and these different
technologies are exclusive to tonal and
you can dial weights up and down
with the touch of a button in one pound
increments using magnets and electricity
so the movement is extremely smooth
and even though i have a home gym
already in my garage
i'm still getting a tonal installed i've
used
tonal for multiple workouts now to do
things i just cannot do
in my home gym such as the chop and lift
exercises from the 4-hour body all sorts
of cable exercises that would usually
involve much much bigger piece of
equipment eccentric
training for instance you can do to give
a simple example
bicep curls where you are lifting let's
just say
20 pounds in each hand up and then tonal
will automatically
increase the weight because you can
lower more than you can lift to say
25 or 30 pounds on the way down and i do
kettlebell swings i do all sorts of
deadlifts this that and the other thing
and after one workout
on tonal focusing on pulling i was
blasted for a full
week it's really incredible what you can
do with eccentrics
they also have all sorts of other really
really cool
advantages that you can apply to any of
your favorite movements
tonal learns from your strength and
provides suggested weight
recommendations for every move with
detailed progress reports to help you
see your strengths grow
tonal also has a growing library of
expert-led workouts by motivating
coaches from strength training
to cardio so you can do really just
about everything every program is
personalized
to your body using artificial
intelligence and other
aspects of the engineering and smart
features
check your form in real time just like a
personal trainer so
try it out try tonal at least check it
out watch the
videos on youtube and see if you can
pick out a familiar voice
it's not me i'll say that but try tonal
the world's smartest home gym
for 30 days in your home and if you
don't love it you can return it for a
full refund
so visit www.tonal
for 100 off of smart accessories when
you use promo code tim
tim at checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim tonal be your strongest
this episode is brought to you by
shipstation the holiday season is fast
approaching and we know that people will
be buying more stuff
online than ever before all of these
trends to e-commerce have been
accelerated due to covid and much more
if you're an e-commerce seller are you
ready to meet the demands of
record-breaking online shopping season
be ready with shipstation
shipstation.com is the fastest
easiest and most affordable way to
manage and ship your orders
in just a few clicks you're managing
orders printing out discounted shipping
labels and getting your products
out fast happier holidays for you and
your customers shipstation takes the
hassle out of holiday shipping
no matter where you're selling on amazon
etsy your website via shopify or other
platforms
shipstation brings all of your orders
into one simple
interface and shipstation works with all
of the major carriers usps
fedex ups even international you can
compare
and choose the best shipping solution
every time and you can access the same
postage discounts that are usually
reserved for large fortune 500 companies
it's no wonder that shipstation is the
number one choice of online sellers and
right now
my listeners that's you guys can try
shipstation free
for 60 days when you use offer code tim
just go to the homepage shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in
tim tim that's it go to shipstation.com
then enter offer code tim
shipstation.com
make ship happen
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking
can i ask
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissues
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show where it
is always my job to
interview and deconstruct world-class
performers from all different fields
my guest today is a dear friend he does
very few podcasts we're going to get
into a disclaimer around that
naval ravikont you can find him at naval
n-a-v-a-l
on twitter he is the co-founder and
chairman of angel list he's an angel
investor and has invested in more than
100
companies including many mega successes
such as twitter uber
notion open door postmates and wish it
is a long
long list you can subscribe to naval his
podcast on wealth and happiness on apple
podcast spotify or wherever
you get your podcast you can also find
his blog at nav.al
for even more neval plus tim that's me
check out my wildly popular interview
with him from 2015
which was nominated for podcast of the
year you can find that and
resources and much more at tim dot blog
slash
naval neval welcome back to the show
yeah thanks for having me
if i recall correctly i was i was
crushed in podcast of the year by jamie
foxx
so that's right
i need weaker competition this time
around if you could just tone it down
this year please
i will do my best yeah jamie jamie
basically i could have been
a completely non-responsive critical
care patient as long as the equipment
functioned jamie foxx is the the
consummate performer so he is he is
formidable competition and podcast but
you are a different breed
and i understand that you get asked to
do podcasts a lot
so what type of disclaimer would you
like to
yeah i don't i don't go on other
people's podcasts anymore i had to make
an exception for you because you're the
og you put me on the map you're a good
friend and frankly i wouldn't even be
known if it weren't for you so i
definitely have to
thank you and honor your request to have
me back
i generally don't do uh podcasts anymore
or at least other people's podcasts for
a couple of reasons
uh first is i just don't believe in
sequels i think sequels suck
right you look at sequels on uh in
movies and
and whatnot and they're usually pretty
bad they cost three times as much
you know they're long-winded the person
now has an ego and a reputation to
defend they've already said what they
were gonna say so they're just repeating
themselves to some level
and you know maybe the first run they
took an idea they've had for a decade or
three decades and they expounded on it
and it sounded great
and then in the sequel whether it's a
book or a movie they have to come up
with something equally good but they
only have two years to do it and it's
just really difficult to do
so i think sequels just make everybody
look bad and i'm not a fan of sequels
yet here we are the thing about sequels
they make money people want them
uh people crave them because there's a
certain familiarity to it but hopefully
we won't embarrass ourselves too much
so yes i don't do sequels we'll make an
exception here and kind of see how it
goes just don't have jamie foxx back on
at least not at least not this year well
i am looking right now
as a framework for starting this
conversation at your twitter account
and that might seem like an odd place
for me to start people who listen to
this show a lot will know that i don't
often do that but i want to know two
things you follow zero people on twitter
yet you have almost a million followers
and also trending right now in the
united states is jamie foxx
hilarious he's right next to you he's
reminding me
this cannot keep this guy down so
let's talk about your account i find
your account fascinating i find your use
of twitter fascinating and i'd like to
begin
with a photograph of a professor at a
blackboard that you have
as your profile suppose header who is
the person in the photograph i think i
recognize this person but i want to hear
you describe
why you chose this photograph and who it
is yeah there
that's uh professor richard feynman um
who was
a a pioneer in the field of quantum
electrodynamics he was part of the
manhattan project
he's known colloquially for his book
surely you're joking mr feynman and a
couple of related ones like
so what do you care what other people
think but he's also
very well regarded in the field of
physics obviously he passed away a while
back but
he invented a lot of quantum
electrodynamics uh feynman path
integrals
um he was part of the manhattan project
uh brilliant brilliant
guy and i loved him because feynman was
one of the first characters that i
encountered
that did science and serious work and
was accomplished in
so-called real life but was also like a
he was a character he was a happy person
he was deeply philosophical
he didn't take himself nor life too
seriously he appreciated the mysteries
of life
he appreciated living life and he had a
lot of fun along the way
so it was kind of a to me he was like a
full stack
intellectual hacker of life and was this
very inspirational to me as a kid
growing up
you know even though i read a lot of
philosophy and
you know just kind of normal non-fiction
my hero and even though i'm in the
business world the tech world my heroes
are scientists because i think
applied science is the engine that pulls
humanity forward it eventually becomes
technology
that technology allows us to engage in
all kinds of pursuits around
civilization rather than be scrapping
for
just basic substance and survival and so
i think scientists are still the most
unsung heroes of human history and
feynman was one of the greats
and he was admirable in many regards as
to how he lived his life although i
think recently they tried to cancel him
but you know they try to cancel
everybody
feynman is a character certainly he is a
character
was a character and a figure who has
fascinated me for decades
and actually i collect very few things
but managed to buy some of his papers
and drawings at auction a handful of
years ago
because it was the first time that they
had been made available so
hey i can show you some of his equations
from the manhattan project which is wild
to think about and my fascination
though is in many respects uninformed
because i don't have
the scientific literacy to fully
appreciate
the genius that he brought to bear on
physics for instance but i could
appreciate his cleverness and
his questioning of assumptions and also
his distaste for
uniforms and other accolades
uh most notably some of the prizes that
he was awarded
that he seemed to have particular a
dislike for
on he famously said that science is the
belief in the ignorance of experts
and it's so funny because these days you
know so many people are on twitter
saying believe in science or according
to science and you have to realize
there's no such thing as science with a
capital s
science the foundation of science is
doubt it is all about falsifiability
david deutsch who's kind of one of my
current modern living physicist heroes
is a poparian like he he subscribes to
karl popper's philosophy
and he basically says that you know if
it's not falsifiable it's not scientific
if you can't prove it false if there's
if if you if it's true
up or down or left or right it's not
science it doesn't require belief
you should be able to challenge it at
all times
it should make risky predictions that
are not obvious and those predictions
should then be tested
and you shouldn't be able to after the
fact change the goal move the goal post
or change how
the you know how the predictions were
set up and so
those are the hallmarks of good science
falsifiability
independent verifiability and making
risky and narrow predictions
with details that are hard to vary both
before and after the fact
and that's how you end up with good
science and good explanations not by
people on twitter voting that's politics
so like everything has become politics
now science has become politics too
people are politicized and there's big
science but i think feynman
would be very unhappy with that he was
just a generally happy character and
non-political intended not to get
involved in these things but i think he
would
realize that that is not actually
science but it's it's masquerade's a
science
it's almost becoming social science and
you know going to twitter like nassim
taleb is one of my favorite twitter
followers even though he's a
he's a bit you know cantankerous yeah
he's cantankerous yeah he's
he's he annoys people for sure but you
know you want to hear the truth
you gotta you gotta be prepared to to be
hurt a little bit but
he had a great tweet recently that i
retweeted which i'm sure made a lot of
people mad
where he said the opposite of education
is not ignorance the opposite of
education
is an education in social science and uh
i thought that was hilarious
uh but you know it it hurts because
there's some truth to it if there was no
truths to it it wouldn't hurt at all you
know if i said tim ferriss is fat that
would just bounce right off of you
but if i said you know tim ferriss and
of all or fake gurus that might hit us
right because we suspect there's some
deep level there's a part of that that's
true
so i think the same way like with you
know social science does kind of lead
you down the road to ignorance because
it's about social and anything social
is about group think and group behavior
and you know individuals can search for
truth but groups search for consensus
because if a group doesn't have
consensus it can't get along if it can't
get along it falls apart and there's
conflict
and so the last place you're going to
find truth is
in large groups and the moment you make
science about
large groups and about voting and about
consensus
you're not really practicing science
anymore yeah and the science with the
capital s is dangerous
very dangerous yeah it's propaganda it's
and
it then it becomes like macroeconomics
again another nut until that line he
says it's easier to macro [ __ ] than
it's a micro [ __ ]
and so big science is the equivalent of
macroeconomics
whereas the equivalent of microeconomics
a little science which is you know me in
a lab or
me with my computer and trying out
various things and so
you can just like with macroeconomics
you can pick and choose
whatever data you want to prove whatever
point you want with big science you can
pick or choose whatever papers you want
so look at the fights right now on the
internet about what covid means
you can go down that hall of mirrors and
find
scientific quote-unquote substantiation
for
many points of view depending on which
papers you choose to cherry pick and so
then we reduce back to consensus
but again science isn't done by
consensus it should be done by
experimentation verifiability
falsifiability
rigorous testing and you know in an
ideal science world you don't
go and survey 10 000 scientists you
actually pick the one smartest scientist
but that's very hard to do now no one
can agree on who the smartest scientist
is so unfortunately i think that the
nature of what science is is being
corrupted and that started
the day we let the so-called social
sciences masquerade as sciences
you know the day we said psychology is a
science and politics can be a science
and
and so on and you can apply the
scientific methods to those things then
i think that's the day we start to
corrupt science
or at least the word science so real
science you know
these days is relegated to a very small
corner you know physics
maybe like molecular biology and
chemistry mathematics
theory of computation but it's a fairly
limited set yeah yeah
very quantitatively
uh literate friend of mine
said at one point most of the
disciplines that have science at the end
of them
are not actually science all right some
exceptions right so yeah compute
computer science computer science
science if it's hard neuroscience
it might be an exception but very often
if there's science appended to it
it is not in fact something that is
falsifiable according to
someone like karl popper right it cannot
be it cannot be proven
or disproven using experiment at least
that's right if there isn't some
experiment could that could
theoretically disprove it then it's not
science
um yeah it's like honest abe's law firm
right
he if he needs to put honest in the
title then you have to wonder
so the same way if they put science in
the word other than as you said computer
science and neuroscience you sort of
have to wonder
well let's look at a couple of quotes
from feynman there are there are few
that i think about a lot and these these
are on goodreads but
number one and i think this is really
applicable
with respect to science in media
particularly a term that bothers me a
lot which is
studies prove or studies show just like
capital s
science shows which isn't really a thing
the facts can get contorted quite a lot
the quote from feynman
is i learned very early the difference
between knowing the name of something
and knowing something
right yeah this is a very deep point and
i think that a lot of times that we just
define something
with another definition or we just throw
out a piece of jargon as if that means
we know something and
you know it's a difference between
memorization and understanding
understanding is the thing that you want
you want to be able to describe it in 10
different ways
in simple sentences from the ground up
and rederive whatever you need
if you just memorize you're lost so i
think this is one of the things that i
get stuck on a lot which is like just
keep going back and reading the basics
over and over trying to understand them
so don't necessarily have that tall
edifice of knowledge that is very
seductive in academia
but as anyone who's operated much in the
real world knows in the real world you
get paid for making good judgments and
decisions based on the basics
for example if you know arithmetic
statistics probability
at a high level and you understand some
basic math
you have all the math that you need to
succeed in life you don't need
calculus or even trigonometry or number
theory or set theory or any of these
kinds of things unless you're
going into a deeply technical field or
mathematics
yet we spend so much of our time in
school covering pre-calc and calculus
when
the kids who are taking those courses
aren't even that good at basic math
so the basics are really important
that's the steel frame the foundation
for understanding that you need to get
through life
and uh too much of it is reduced to
memorization and
understanding things as names and as
definitions
and i think the feynman example is you
know his dad would take him for walks
and they would see birds and
you know if his dad would say this bird
is uh such and such a warbler but
that doesn't tell you anything about the
bird that tells you about humans and
humans gave that bird that name
really the bird you know it likes to
stand on one leg
at this point it likes to pick it uh
lice and it's feathers doing this and it
likes to eat these kinds of things and
it flies you know this way for that
reason and these are its predators and
these are its prey
so i mean those are the kinds of things
that really give you understanding
who cares what the bird is called the
name of the bird is irrelevant
and you see a lot of professions in
professional life this happens a lot
which is jargon people try to protect
their knowledge
by basically saying well i understand
this term and that term and what this
term means
but the reality is most people don't
actually know what these things
mean underneath i find this very common
in accounting a lot of business people
don't know accounting and even a lot of
accountants
will have fancy words for things but
when you dig underneath they don't
really understand the principle of
what's going on below it
and if you just understand the
principles and even if you don't
understand the words you will have an
advantage
in for example negotiating deals because
you'll understand underneath how the
pieces are actually moving on the board
as opposed to what they're called
and i just want to point out developing
that
foundational knowledge
is akin to learning the basics of
shooting foul throws in basketball
it is not becoming michael jordan right
with a very limited
set of colors with which to paint if you
spend
a few weeks maybe not even a few weeks a
few days with a decent
youtube tutorial or book gathering the
basics of accounting you will be able to
make significantly better decisions
right i mean it's it's i just want to
underscore that this is not a
master's degree or phd or any type of
commitment like that
that can separate you from the pack in
terms of advantage
well just just run a business run
unlimited stand it'll teach you better
accounting not a textbook
now you may need to learn certain
conventions because you need those to
communicate with other humans so that
there's efficient communication when you
say one thing they understand that thing
and that's where jargon can be useful
because it can be a compressed way of
communicating knowledge
rather than having to you know try and
explain it from first principles every
time
but when it's not useful is when it
becomes a substitute for understanding
understanding is a thing
you know that's what separates humans
from the other animals that's what
separates us from the robots that we
actually understand
what's going on underneath like for
example in the artificial intelligence
world there's a new algorithm gpt3 which
is the rage which is text completion
so people are saying hey i can make up
like really plausible sounding writing
and so the ai is here is going to take
all the jobs well no because the ai
doesn't actually know what's going on
underneath
if i were to ask a question well why did
you write that or what does that mean it
would very quickly fall apart
so you always want to strive for
understanding not for memorization
you should be able to rearticulate it
five different ways in every language
that you know
otherwise you don't really understand it
and the good news is you don't have to
understand
that many things you know while we're on
the topic of find a fineman
one of the phrase the quotes from him is
he says like you know
nature uses only the longest threads to
weave her tapestry
and so what he means by that is that
there's only a few basic principles that
you have to understand to kind of
understand the sum total of
our knowledge in physics there's not a
lot and as
physics becomes more and more advanced
we're actually unifying
theories we're collapsing them into one
thing like we do with electricity and
magnetism or
statistical mechanics and heat and
thermodynamics you know those turn out
to be one thing
so we're or we're trying to do currently
with gravity and quantum mechanics we're
trying to reconcile them in quantum
loop gravity or in string theory or what
have you so
you just kind of have to understand a
few of the basic things and then you'll
see them recurring over and over and
over again
like for example i study and read
physics in computer science just for
entertainment i don't
there's no practical application for me
but
there's this really interesting theory i
was reading about called solomonoff
induction
and it's basically formalized as occam's
razor which is that the shortest answer
is the correct one
but it's it's more advanced than that
but it basically says like if you want
to figure out
why something happened you take all the
different reasons why it could have
happened all the different theories why
it could have happened
and then you sort of weigh each of them
based on
how compressed they are how how short
they are how likely they are
and then that gives you the probability
that kind of gives you
the the explanation for why that theory
happened now feynman has a very
similar and elegant thing in a
completely different field
where he basically says if you want to
understand why this particle took that
path why did this photon take that path
what you do is you look at all the
possible paths that photon could have
taken and you sort of
weigh them you you sum them
probabilistically based on how likely
that path was
it's actually the same observation
except one is about
photons traveling through space-time and
the other is about the causality and
why an event may have happened and what
the theory is behind that
and these are two completely different
fields and two completely different
characters thinking about two completely
different things
and these are very very fundamental
theories in their fields
but deep down they're actually the same
which to me is fascinating
it just shows how much of what we
look at as complexity actually emerges
from a set of very simple
rules and it's just fascinating so
understanding is a thing to strive for
not the words so even though you use the
fancy words like solomon of induction
and
and finance path integral theory
whatever the heck it's called i don't
even know what the
actual name is the name is irrelevant
it's the concept that's
that's fascinating you spoke to learning
accounting through
building a business let's segue to
business your pin tweet
is a tweet storm so it's a series of
tweets
the headline of which is how to get rich
and then in parentheses without getting
lucky
it has as we record this 44.8
000 retweets 110 plus thousand
favorites we're not going to go through
this whole thing it's quite long but i'm
curious to know
what parts of it you think people are
paying too much attention
to or overemphasize and what parts of it
do you wish people
would pay more attention to because
there are many different pieces of
advice
in this thread that tweet storm is a
series of principles
that i kind of wrote for myself in my
head when i was 13 and i was trying to
figure out how to make money
and i kind of came with a framework of
how to be rich but not by accident to do
it in a way that
i could repeat it over and over and i
would leave very little up the chance
because i think there's kind of this
it's not completely mythology but
there's this belief that you know to
make money you either have to be born
rich or you have to be privileged or you
have to be in the right circles or to
get lucky
and i think that there are still ways to
accomplish the original american dream
which is you know make money but do it
in a deliberate systematic way and when
i say money i mean wealth
i don't mean like a law firm where you
make you know a couple hundred bucks an
hour but you're still
tied to the clock i mean like when you
wake up when you want you go to sleep
when you want
you know you live where you want and you
have freedom so to me the purpose of
money is freedom
and for that you need to create wealth
and can you do it ethically can you do
it sustainably can you do it reliably
can you do it
with people that you like can you do it
doing things that you enjoy
and i think it's absolutely possible and
i i'd like to think that i'm at least
one of many living proof points for that
you know warren buffett and charlie
munger are
examples of others uh not that i'm in
their status of their league but you
know other people have done it so
that was the whole point of that
framework and the tweet storm i just
wrote it down one day and
it's funny because obviously i have some
experience at twitter so i know how to
craft things
but i think that was written back in the
day when the tweet limit was 140
characters too so it's harder
but i just woke up one night when i've
been thinking about it and i wrote up
the whole tweetstorm almost exactly like
you see it
and there are lots and lots of missing
pieces like obviously that is just like
a very high level
very zen cone like or or haiku like or
even
hallmark card like framework it's
missing a ton of details which i then
tried to extrapolate on in my podcast
series
on the same topic what do people over
emphasize and what are people missing
and actually involved let me pause to
just read a few of them this is from
may 31 2018 so a few examples and you
don't have to comment on these specific
examples but just for people who
haven't seen this i want to give them an
idea so the
second of these various tweets in this
sequence is understand that ethical
wealth creation is possible if you
secretly despise wealth it will elude
you
end of that particular tweet and then
there's another one you're not going to
get rich renting out your time you must
own equity a piece of a business to gain
your financial freedom
that one right there is the most
important one which is
you basically in modern life what
happens is like
the person who is the best at doing
something in the world will get to do it
for the entire world through a
combination of leverage and distribution
accountability and specific knowledge
with all of which i talk about in the
tweet storm
if you're the best in the world doing
something like if you're the best
teacher in the world at math you should
be teaching the entire world math
if you're the best podcast interviewer
you should be doing all the top
interviews and the returns will accrue
to you
especially in this highly digital world
where we live in where the cost of
distributing something is very close to
zero
and so what you kind of want to do is
you want to productize yourself
into a business and then you want to own
that business that is the way to make
wealth
a clear example is that tim ferriss
podcast the tim ferriss brand right
you're it's an eponymous brand
your name is on it you're leveraged
through this podcast and through the
books that you write
and through the army of followers that
you have on the various media platforms
and you're taking on big accountability
and their specific knowledge only you
know how to be tim ferriss the learning
machine who can then connect to other
learners
and extract value out of them and share
that with the audience
so that's an example of you having
productized yourself but ultimately you
own the tim ferriss business
now you can go lower levels down from
that you don't have to own the entire
business you could be an investor in
public equities or private stocks you
could be
a partner in a private business uh you
could be an employee a startup where you
have stock options but
if you don't own a piece of a business
you're gonna it's gonna be extremely
hard to get wealthy it'll be nearly
impossible almost not worth
that route so i think that is the most
important foundational tweet
i think where people kind of all kind of
miss the plot the most though
is we have pain avoidance in life we
don't want to
face things where it's clear we've made
bad decisions because one good
definition of suffering is
that's the moment when you see things
that they clearly are and you kind of
don't like what you see
like for example if you if you and your
spouse have been fighting for a long
time
you know you've kind of been sweeping
under the rug and you've sort of been
suffering along but you're sweeping on
the wrong
and then you get divorced at that moment
you can no longer unsee all the damage
that was in the relationship and what
all the consequences are they're real
the same way if you haven't been taking
care of your health but then suddenly
you find out that you've just fallen off
a cliff
and something irreversibly bad has
happened the moment of suffering arrives
and you're in pain because you can no
longer
unsee this thing you can no longer avoid
it so i think the same way
the unfortunate part is that a lot of
these principles are written for young
people because
you can set yourself on a certain
trajectory in life earlier and so
for example if you went you got a you
know a phd in a social science and now
i'm basically saying hey learn the code
you're going to avoid that you're not
going to want to see that because you
have all this sunk
cost in the degree so i think a lot of
people don't want to pick up the new
skills that are necessary or they don't
want to for example physically
move or they don't want to disappoint
the people in the relationships that
they already have to make room for new
relationships
so everybody wants to start where they
are nobody wants to go back down the
mountain to find the path going to the
top
everybody wants to stay on the path
they're on maybe make a few tweaks and
get to the top
or like charlie munger jokes you know
people always ask me like how do i get
to be rich like you except quicker
i don't want to be the old rich guy i
want to be the young rich guy so i think
these are the hard parts the
the the hard parts are not the learning
is the unlearning it's not the climbing
up the mountain it's the going back down
to the bottom of the mountain and
starting over
it's the beginner's mind that every
great artist or every great business
person has
which is you have to be willing to start
from scratch you have to be willing to
hit reset
and go back to zero because you have to
realize that what you
already know and what you're already
doing is actually an impediment to your
full potential
and most people just don't want to
acknowledge that and i'm guilty of that
too that's just human nature i'm not i'm
not
faulting anybody for it but it's just
human nature
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008 crisis you would
have missed out on fifty percent
five zero percent of your returns don't
miss out on the best days in the market
stay invested in a long-term automated
investment portfolio wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees
and lower your taxes takes about three
minutes to sign up and then wealthfront
will build you a globally diversified
portfolio of etfs based on your risk
appetite and manage it for you at an
incredibly low cost
wealthfront software constantly monitors
your portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay
on your investment gains their newest
service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account
they've really thought of a ton they've
checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you
go to wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today
and you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life that's
wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today
at wealthfront.com tim
and if we look at your specific case as
it relates
to equity you mentioned owning part of a
business you also mentioned
in this conversation productizing
yourself so would you view
your success in following that principle
predominantly
in for instance the equity that you own
in a
company like angellist or is it the
identity
and the brand meaning associations that
you've built as
naval the human or is it slash investor
therefore
being sought after as an investor or is
it something else how would you think
of that principle as applying yeah
most in your own life because you've
created wealth not just through
say your equity and angel list but also
through many successful investments
and then i'm sure there are other ways
that we could identify
wealth as is coming from your path that
you know
what i what i like about my path is that
i've made money doing a lot of different
little things so i've made you know
money consistently in sort of
small to medium-sized chunks i haven't
had like one gigantic payday that set me
up forever although it depends on your
standards right i'm talking about by
silicon valley standards obviously for
most parts of the world i've had many of
those gigantic paydays
but they've been consistent and they've
been varied varied in the sense of that
there are completely different kinds of
investments and endeavors but consistent
in that i get one every couple of years
which would i just want to interject for
a second which would seem to
suggest that there is a there are
principles
guiding your approaches or absolutely
right therefore yeah you're not relying
on winning the powerball lottery or that
equivalent
no not at all no there's no lottery here
to win the lottery
is for losers lotteries are just attacks
on people who can't do math
uh yet rich get rich quick schemes are
just other people getting rich off of
you there are no shortcuts
so what i'm doing is i'm taking my
specific knowledge
which is my ability to understand deeply
technical concepts
and communicate them to the rest of the
world to be an interface between great
programmers and developers and designers
and the capital markets and consumers
and using that to put myself in a
position where then i can identify great
trends as they're emerging
invest in those companies or help start
those companies own equity in those
things
help bring them to market help do the
strategy on how to navigate the worlds
of fundraising and exiting and
recruiting and company building and
cultures and
technology development and all that and
have a brand around it
and i use that to kind of make money and
that is just one of several ways you
know i've also
done it by investing early on in public
markets and cryptocurrencies and
starting funds and all kinds of things
but i i don't
it's funny i don't really follow my own
principles anymore like for example the
whole podcast thing and the whole
twitter thing
even though i've got reasonably good
brands and followers and those i'm not
monetizing them at all i'm not charging
anybody for anything
because i'm not trying to make money
anymore to me like making money is like
you become the kind of person that makes
money and you put yourself in long-term
situations where you're always going to
make money so i have the brand and i
have
deep relationships with a dozen people
who i know and i trust that i can do
business with for the rest of my life
and they're very high integrity people
they're very capable people and just
makes it easy to do things
so i've set up that infrastructure now
the money just kind of makes itself as i
go about my life
i don't want to have to work hard i
don't have to roll out of bed at a
certain time i don't have to answer to
somebody
so i optimize for independence and
freedom i could have made a lot more
money by
raising a huge fund or joining a big vc
firm early on or being exec at one of
the massive companies in silicon valley
early on
but i always optimize for independence
i'm lazy you know i wake up at
7 8 9 10 a.m i go to sleep at
2 30 a.m you know i don't work a lot of
days
uh some days i work morning tonight but
it's just based on whatever i'm curious
about i never want to have to answer to
a boss no one's ever going to tell me
what to do
i don't want to order people around i
don't want to have someone reporting to
me and kind of asking me all the time
what to do
i want peer relationships i want to flow
i want to be able to do business while
walking you know in a forest talking on
a cell phone or
sitting in a meeting or in front of a
computer or i want to be on a beach if i
don't feel like it
the ideal would be to make money with
your mind not with your time so if i can
just make one good decision a year
and that makes me all the money that i
need for that year then that's perfect
and that's the way it should be because
we're living in an age of infinite
leverage and your judgment just gets
multiplied
through this massive force multiplier
through code capital community
labor what have you so if you're smart
and you kind of know what you're doing
you don't need to work hard working hard
is the last
least important thing you have to pay
your dues you have to put in all the
iterations ten thousand iterations not
ten thousand
hours to figure out what to do and how
to do it well but once you know
you don't have to put in the time
anymore it's your judgment and the
judgment comes from clear thinking the
clear thinking comes from having
time to reflect and to pursue your
genuine intellectual curiosity
and you'll see that a lot of the great
investors for example just sit around
reading most of the time or warren
buffett famously plays a lot of bridge
obviously not everyone can be just an
investor although that is becoming more
and more democratized
and i've picked something that suits my
temperament and particular capabilities
but there's lots and lots of ways to
make money if you apply your mind to it
so i don't work to make money i mean if
i make so much money that i'm donating
hospital wings and universities and all
that stuff i overshot
you know i'm not trying to have some
influence on the world through money and
ironically i have more influence on the
world through podcasts like this
and so you know making more money
doesn't change my life
it doesn't change the world as much as i
could by doing other things
so there's not much incentive for me to
make money anymore other than just
practicing
my craft well let's let's talk about
a few of your your missives missives is
probably not the right word yeah i'm not
telling you
anything i'm not trying to persuade
anyone of anything so
if people don't like it you know some
people get triggered on twitter and they
start arguing it's like just leave
just don't listen to it the one i'm
going to read would be a great one for
people to get really upset about
or i would find it comical to to look at
the comments
people are upset but the the line is
this imagine how effective you would be
if you weren't anxious all the time
why did you put this out and have you
seen
highly anxious people become people who
experience very little anxiety is that
something you've seen but first
why did you put this up what was behind
it and then have you seen anxious people
become
largely i guess unanxious or non-anxious
people
yeah most of my tweets are not very
deliberate or thought through
what's happening is i've been thinking
about some concept for
you know months years whatever it's been
percolating and then all of a sudden
it'll come to me it's sort of in like
one spiffy sentence where i'm like oh
this is how i will remember this thing
this is how i can distill this down into
a pointer for myself
so that when i need to make decisions i
can retrieve
that whole line of reasoning and so
where this comes from is basically
like everybody after a certain age i am
taking responsibility
for my own happiness and peace and
quality of life
and one of the things you learn after
you make money is that
money doesn't make you happier it takes
care of your money problems but it's
not necessarily going to put you in a
place where you're in some kind of bliss
all the time
in fact there's nothing out there that
will make you happy forever
so you sort of have to take
responsibility for guiding yourself
in such a way that your mental state
ends up where you want it
and so i've been working on my mental
state and i have
you know working is a big word i don't i
don't want to say i've been working on
it but i would say my mental state has
gotten to a place which is much better
than it used to be
and people will often say well i don't
want to do that because it will take
away my ambition
i want to succeed right now and so
i've thought about that a fair bit and
is that true or not well certainly for
me in the last few years since i've
become calmer
my effectiveness has gone through the
roof and i've been more successful
but it's hard to disambiguate that from
well also maybe you're just later in
your career you're in a better position
for it and that's a valid criticism
so one of the things i've been trying to
figure out is like would i have been as
successful
and it's hard to do the counterfactual
obviously if i wasn't as anxious because
anxiety is you know comes from fear it's
also a motivator it makes you get off
your butt
and one of the ways to make the anxiety
go away at least until the next
piece of anxiety comes along is to go do
something about it
so what is the role of anxiety well
firstly i noted
that pretty much everybody's anxious all
the time it's a rare human being who
isn't anxious
and it makes sense we're alpha predators
you know we took over this earth and
domesticated or killed all the other
animals
and we did that by being the most
paranoid the most fearful the most angry
predators this world has ever
seen so anxiety is built into the core
of who we are
in fact you could argue that all the
mind does all day long is
fear-based scenario planning for
survival and then maybe a little bit of
greed for replication
so anxiety is at the core level of who
we are but certainly
some people are more anxious than others
there's no question and some people seem
to be much calmer about it so
which is more useful for effectiveness
so assuming that your goal is your
motivation is intrinsic
you're doing the thing because you love
it or because you really want it
and you can separate that motivation
from
anxiety then i think you can take on
certain superpowers and we kind of all
intrinsically know this like if you look
at you know samurai warriors right like
uh
miyamoto musashi is in a duel with
somebody else you know that the person
who is calmer is going to win
in all those movies it's the one who can
like who's like
incredibly still then swipes with a
sword incredibly quickly and then still
again that's the winner the one who has
a zen state of mind
similarly in the terminator movies part
of the reason you fear the terminator is
because he's a robot he's unstoppable
he's implacable
you can't argue with him you can't
communicate with him you can't make him
slow down
and he has no remorse he just keeps
coming or in that old clinton movie
unforgiven you know the guy who wins the
gunfight is the one who doesn't flinch
he's just keeping his cool
while he's loading his gun and shooting
he's not like all over the place running
around
so i just think we waste so much energy
through anxiety
that if you can be calm and still go
about your business it's a superpower
and i i realized this myself recently
where i was in a conflict situation in
business it was a high conflict
situation it was unfortunate we
i think we've solved it but as i went
through this high conflict situation
i'd been through one like it years
before where i was much more anxious and
i remember that time period i remember
how much i was sweating it
and how nervous i was and how i went
through bouts of fear and anger and
and how kind of worked up i was the
entire time intense and didn't get much
sleep
but this time i was incredibly calm and
i was almost enjoying it because it was
like practicing my craft now of course
it's easier to do now because i have
more money
but at the same time it just didn't
bother me it was just very mechanical
and because of that i could be very
effective about it and i could be
effective about it while
doing lots and lots of other things my
mind wasn't constantly spinning in a
whirlpool
taking on 10 different problems and just
fear based on aeroplaning all the time
most of these things were never going to
happen so i do believe that being
calm and still going about your business
is the superpower
now yes if anxiety is your only
motivator then you have a problem but i
would argue
the pure motivations don't come out of
anxiety so let's talk about
attribution here to what would you
attribute the
and i know this that it's difficult to
isolate variables etc but
if let's just say like you have a family
so let's just say one of your kids comes
to you
it's like dad i'm suffering from a lot
of anxiety
what should i do or you observe it and
you want to help your kid out
what types of recommendations would you
make or might you make
another question if you prefer it is
what has helped
you to go from the whirlpool experience
of anxiety
in high conflict experience round one
versus calm naval and high conflict
experience round two
yeah it's really hard to separate all
the pieces out i mean it comes from a
combination
of philosophy yoga meditation
getting older having kids you know like
you i've
i've had some psychedelic experiences
but those are
very far back in the past um just a
distant memory at this point
but i would say the number one thing
that has been very very important for me
is meditation
and it's a stupid thing to say because
it's so trite everybody just says it now
but when i say meditation i don't mean
sitting there and watching your breath
or chanting a mantra i mean
self-examination
and meditation is a great way to do that
self-therapy it's sitting there with
your
thoughts so anxiety the anxiety anxiety
this this pervasive
non-specific anxiety we're just
constantly on
edge about everything that comes from an
unexamined life
you know i think what's the socrates
said like an unexamined life is not
worth living i forget who said that
quote something like that yeah but
it's it's arithmetic one of those one of
those smart philosopher types but
it's correct it's your unexamined life
that is causing the problems and you can
examine it in multiple ways
you can examine it through you can have
some crazy mushroom trip where it all
comes out one night you could
do a lot of meditation sitting there
with yourself and letting your mind run
crazy and then seeing
what's actually in your mind that your
mind wants to tell you and have you
listened to
and have you resolved that is unresolved
it could be through therapy
it could be through reading lots of
philosophy and reflection and long walks
so there's many many ways to tackle it
but it's that spending that time with
yourself to examine
why are you having these thoughts think
about it this way
we spend so much time in our
relationships our relationship with our
wives our relationship with our
colleagues our relations to our business
partners our relations with our friends
the most important relationship you have
is with yourself it's with this voice in
your head that is constantly rattling
every waking hour it's this crazy
roommate living inside your mind
who's always chattering always
chattering never shuts up
and you can't control these thoughts
they just come up out of you don't even
know where
that quality of those quality of your
thoughts that convers those
conversations you're having in your head
all the time
that is your world that is the world you
live in those that's the world view you
have
that's the lenses you see through and
that's going to determine the quality of
your life more than anything else and if
you want to see what the quality of your
life actually is
put down the drink put down the computer
put down the smartphone put down the
book put down the headphones
just sit by yourself doing nothing and
then you will know what the quality of
your life
actually is because that's what you're
always running away from that's why
people when they try to meditate to sit
down like
i hate it i can't sit still why because
your mind is eating you live your life
is unexamined
your mind is running in loops over
things that it has not resolved
and because they're not resolved when
you run around in your normal life
it's not those problems have gone away
it's that they're just there they're
there
but they're provoking anxiety and what
you think of as the anxiety that's
that's kind of consuming you and you
can't identify the source
that's just the tip of an iceberg poking
out from underneath the water
and underneath this giant pile of
garbage of decisions that were made
without too much thought of situations
that you're in that you haven't resolved
that you need to resolve
of problems that you have or desires
that you have that have gone
unmet or unmanifested or contradictions
that you're living in or ways that you
which you feel trapped
so proper meditation proper examination
should ruin the life that you're
currently living it should cause you to
leave relationships
it should cause you to re-establish
boundaries with family members
with colleagues it should cause you to
quit your job it should cause you to
change your eating patterns it should
cause you to spend more time with
yourself it should cause you to change
what books you read
it should cause you to change who your
friends are if it doesn't do that it's
not real examination if it doesn't come
attached with destruction
of your current life then you can't
create the new life
in which you will not have the anxiety
or at least
parts of it not necessarily whole cloth
so let's ask
let's let's dive into meditation because
as you mentioned it's a term that is
used a lot and in the minds of most
it is represented by things that you
just said
you do not do like the mantra based
meditation or following the breath
and you and i have meditated before i
don't know if your approach is still
similar but it is quite
a i'd hate to talk about trite paradigm
shift in a sense
at least in the way that i experienced
it alongside you
at one point which was literally
doing nothing for extended periods of
time i don't know if that's still the
case but could you
describe the practice a bit because it's
it was such a burden lifted in a sense
when the pass fail is removed
and the experience that i had after say
a week of doing this twice a day which
is not necessarily what people do in
normal life but
it was pretty profound so could you
describe
the current practice which may be
different from what i experienced
yeah i actually have two different
things that i do and i almost hate
calling it meditation
because everyone has in their mind a
preconceived notion of what meditation
is let's not even call it that
i would say that there are two
self-examination practices that i do
and i don't even call them practices
anymore because sometimes i do them
because i feel like them and i enjoy
them or because it feels right and
sometimes i don't
because anything done routinely sort of
becomes its own trap
and is not going to get you anywhere it
just becomes like another spiritual high
another checkbox right
now is it fair though to say that you're
able to opt
in and out now because you had a certain
front loading period
doing it consistently actually i'll say
there are three different things that i
do and i'll go through
them the first is i just read a lot of
philosophy especially at night time
before i go to bed
which ones schopenhauer maxims who are
we talking about yeah schopenhauer
western philosophy is my current
favorite
uh although i've definitely moved around
on that one eastern philosophy i'll read
everything from osho i know he's
discredited and been canceled but
fantastic that makes me like him even
more
um krishnamurti i don't know kapil gupta
uh rupert spira i mean it's all over the
place uh
anthony demelo he's fantastic actually
i'm gonna start with one book start with
anthony demelo's way to love
um or his book awareness they're both
really good um
but there's a ton of them i basically
read a lot of philosophers siddhartha
vasis says yoga
bhagavad gita the daodecheng you know
i'm always going through one of these
books at any given time and usually
rereading
for inspiration and i'll read these at
night usually there'll be one or two
things i'll catch on to
it'll i'll reflect on it before i go to
sleep so that is a form of
self-examination and
it's it's not done because it's a
formula it's done because i'm genuinely
interested in these things so it's not
work to me it's fun
the second thing that i do is which i've
been doing for a long time now is
just trying to be aware of my thoughts
and not in a
you know sit there and be like oh i'm
gonna be aware of my thoughts kind of
way but just
realizing that a lot of these thoughts
that come up aren't unbidden i don't
control them it's not like i decided to
have this thought i don't even know what
i'm saying to you right now it's coming
out of my mouth
at the same time as i'm thinking it so
where is this coming from
who is this person what is this person
saying is this true
is it correct has it been correct in the
past
is he just being paranoid now is he
being crazy what are his underlying
motivations and i'm not even questioning
so much
but more just kind of seeing it and
after a while when you see it you start
seeing through your own bs
you start seeing how you're mainly just
justifying whatever the heck you want to
believe
because it's good for your survival it's
good for your replication or it's good
for your money or it's going to get you
late or any of these various things
and when you're doing that reflection is
it sitting at a table pen and paper is
it
half lotus with your eyes closed what is
it no it's literally just walking around
it's just walking around
it's nice it's just life just just if
you say something to me i'm always going
to
listen to it with a slightly critical
filter because you're external to me
applying that same filter to my own
thoughts gives me a level of peace and
distance from them and the ability to
see through my own bs
which i think makes my life better so
i've just found that to be a useful
thing
way of life but there are lots of times
where i forget to do it i get caught up
in some emotions some runaway train of
thought but
usually these days i can catch myself
and be like oh okay i'm in that mindset
again i'm having that mode of reactions
again
and when the mind sort of sees me
chattering it quiets down a bit right
and like i said it's that back to that
crazy roommate analogy which i
originally picked up from michael singer
by the way he has a good book called the
untethered soul
but you know the room the crazy roommate
analogy like you would eventually tell
your roommate to shut up
or you would tell them to start
justifying their claims or you would at
least
at some level you start dismissing them
for just kind of rambling all the time
in this fear paranoia mode so i think
just kind of
viewing your thoughts as sort of these
unbidden things that arise from within
you
but aren't really necessarily the whole
story and should be viewed with the same
level of skepticism
that you would apply to an outside
observer i think that frame work is
helpful and if you find it to be true
then you'll find yourself doing it more
often if you find it not to be true if
you're like no actually i choose these
thoughts and
i want to have them and that's who i am
and this all makes sense to me
then you can stop viewing it with a
critical eye that's up to you
but the last one is the one that i think
people think of as more traditionally
meditation which is sitting down
and meditating and on that one i learned
from an indian gentleman
same same character you learned from who
i had a very simple system and i just
found it the most compelling form of
meditation i've ever tried
which is you sit there for 60 minutes so
unfortunately not less than an hour at a
time because it takes 30 to 40 minutes
to sink in
past the initial chattering so you get
to the good part or the so-called
runner's high equivalent
and you sit for 60 minutes every day and
you do it for at least 60 days and you
do it first thing in the morning it's
been your
mind is clear and you're alert and
you've had a good night's sleep
and you sit up with your back straight
and you can use cushions or you can use
a chair or whatever there's no magic
position
and just whatever happens happens
whatever your mind wants to do you just
let it do if it wants to talk you let it
talk if you wants to fight you let it
fight
wants to be quiet you let it be quiet if
it wants to chant a mantra or pay
attention to breathing you can do that
but you don't force anything you just
kind of let it happen
and so you don't fight it you don't
resist it you don't argue with it you
don't double down on it
we just kind of let things happen and
when you do that
for at least 60 days my experience has
been that you kind of clear out your
mental inbox and all the craziness that
was going on
all the chattering will come out some
problems will get resolved you will have
some
epiphanies you will make changes to your
life some will be self-examination
some of you just get tired of some of it
just needs to be heard once and then it
goes away
and eventually you'll get to a mental
state of inbox zero
where now you're just thinking about
what happened yesterday you're kind of
caught up and your mind is relatively
clear
and just your anxiety level goes down
you're living more peacefully and i've
been doing this for about two and a half
years now
and i probably missed about a dozen days
total and but there are some days where
i've done two hours a day or more
and i will tell you that is the single
most important thing that i do
it is a sheer joy much of it is highly
entertaining pleasurable sometimes it's
just flat it's nothingness
i can't even tell you why i do it i
can't even tell you what's going on in
that state
but i will tell you that that time spent
by myself is the most important time
that i have
and thanks to that i am now much more
self-contained i don't feel like i need
other people
i don't need external sources of
pleasure or happiness all the time
i drink less i'm not attracted to trying
any drugs whatsoever
it's just life is easier it's more
pleasant i don't take things as
seriously
i'm not afraid of my mortality as much
anymore i don't fear aging i don't
i don't lust after things i don't have
this constant pervasive
need to find something outside of me to
make my life better
when the best hour of my day is spent by
myself
then the world has very little to offer
me and i can still participate in it
but it doesn't have that grip on me that
it used to i don't fear solitary
confinement
and i think that is a superpower and i
think everyone should have it everyone
does have it it's easy
it requires doing nothing it's your
birthright you can't fail at it there's
no there's no way to fail at it
literally all you have to do is just sit
down and close your eyes and just just
be by give yourself a break for an hour
every day just take the time off
from the world a few follow-ups
krishna murday do you have any any
favorites of his
or anything that you would suggest
someone start with if they have no
familiarity with krishnamurti and i'll
second anthony demelo
also yeah i actually remember starting
with krishna he's a tough one but if
you're going to start somewhere
i started with this book called think on
these things there's also the book of
life
um he's very cerebral very intellectual
and a little confusing
but he definitely speaks truth and he
walks the walk
anthony de mello the way to love uh
osho's book the great challenge
uh and i know people think osho is a
fake guru and all that but he had some
real stuff too he's very articulate
he uh he understood a lot there's a
great
clip from him on soundcloud that says
it's called life has no goals no purpose
uh i listen to that that one a lot
there's a lot of them out there once you
start going down this rabbit hole you'll
find them the classics the bhagavad-gita
get a good translation stephen miller i
think has a good translation
uh he also has a good translation of the
daodaiching those are both really
interesting
again only if it appeals to you i mean
there's ancient wisdom in schopenhauer
read councils and maxims
you know these are smart people
self-reflecting but
overall the point is not to read the
point is to inspire
so that you yourself can reflect and
kappa gupta is an account in twitter he
has a couple of great books direct truth
is a
fantastic book um you know written very
recently and pulls no punches
um but you know all of these are
basically there to inspire
you to self-reflect and if you're not
interested in self-reflection if you're
not at that stage in life then don't do
it it's a waste of time
in fact i would say the reason to do
these things is just because they make
your life better
because they make you more effective
because they have some utility to you
if they do not have utility to you if
they don't make your life better then
drop it it's useless i will also second
the reading of philosophy and this is
not
for kind of idle or abstract
like semantic tail chasing right it's
it's
for whatever reason on a very pragmatic
level deeply soothing
to read the
insights and observations of those who
are considering things
that are not of today they're not of
this week they're not of this month they
are
for much broader periods of time or
timeless in some capacity right
it alleviates some of the manufactured
emergency and urgency
of the [ __ ] that is it upon us by
every possible input oh yeah the news
and twitter are so toxic the human brain
is not
designed to manage every emergency in
the world in real time we're not
designed to process
all the breaking news on the planet in
our heads and this is one of my recent
tweets but
the goal of the media these days is to
make every problem your problem
that's how they get attention it's how
they get clicks you know you have tribal
wars going on
zombies battling each other and they
want to pull you in where
even non-participation is not allowed
anymore neutral bystanders are not
allowed
so it's a crazy world out there there's
a circus going on with the monkeys
flinging feces at each other and they
want to drag you into the fight
really what you want to focus on is
what's timeless timeless is great you
know
the old questions all have old answers
and they're best consumed from the old
practitioners because they were very
clear-minded about it they weren't
busy trying to fit into the politics of
this time they were fitting to the
politics of that time but that's lost to
us now
so actually another great source is i
have your dao seneca series in audible
uh and i listen to it on repeat when i'm
working out a lot so that's so very
kidding yeah those letters to lucilius
uh
amazing yeah amazing stuff and every
time i go through it i learned something
new
yeah the town of seneca the the moral
letters to lucilius if people want to
look on
public domain from on public domain
sources you can find these letters the
moral letters to leukillus
also spelled as you might read lucillus
by seneca and so that's an audiobook
series that that i produced and you can
find the pdfs for free
online as well let's talk about
some brass tack stuff since i think
people will be very interested
you mentioned monkeys throwing feces
tribalism
in times like this this is being
recorded in 2020
and first day of october a lot of
folks are interested in stores of value
they are fearful of what could happen
and considering investments like gold or
cryptocurrency
and i wanted you to explain one of your
recent tweets this is just from
the last few days and it
is crypto stable coins
dash choose between blow up risk
censorship risk and fraud risk
what are crypto stable coins and what
does this tweet mean
yeah just backing up for a second like i
i think cryptocurrencies are probably
one of the greatest inventions
in human history and the reason why
they're interesting is because if you
look at
the technology industry technology plays
in unregulated spaces
it's very hard for technology to change
regulated spaces as uber and postmates
and companies like that find out
but generally the reason technology
works is because it creates its own
frontier it is a digital frontier that
has been created not the physical
frontiers are all closed and the
new world has been colonized and the
wild west has been tamed where do you go
to create new things free of
interference and regulation
and kind of exercise maximum creativity
and so
that's been done mostly in the
technology space and
one of the areas that has been protected
by technological innovation from
technological innovation is wall street
because they're
it's you know they have regulatory
capture very bureaucratic
you know the the money industrial
complex that runs a lot of our economy
and runs a lot of washington dc where 20
of our gdp goes into financial
engineering and into the wall street
casino and so cryptocurrencies are kind
of how we get around that and so they're
sovereign resistant they're designed to
be completely decentralized
you don't need the violent power of the
state to enforce the value of a
cryptocurrency
and it allows for truly trustless
transactions between humans without some
king or authority or government
or corporation having to be in the
middle and so it's very liberating to
disconnect wealth creation wealth
storage
and wealth protection from the state and
that's what cryptocurrencies really
enable
one second let me just pause to say that
at at one point
you and i did a very thorough
cryptocurrency 101 conversation
with a domain super expert named nick
zabo
s-z-a-b-o which people can also find
for more on kind of the the history and
basics of
some of the crypto yeah nick is a
bonafide genius and a pioneer in the
space he also has a great blog called
unenumerated that i highly recommend but
anyway so the best known cryptocurrency
is bitcoin and bitcoin is trying to be
the new gold or the new swiss bank
account kind of all rolled into one
and has some advantages you know as a
store of value it can be stored
digitally so it's hard to seize
it's very easy to verify technologically
speaking unlike gold it's easy to send
across
national boundaries and and
electronically over the internet
it's easily divisible and verifiable
down to its authenticity is very
verifiable where gold is hard to do
it can be divided down to millions and
trillions of a bitcoin very very easily
it is somewhat programmable so you can
put it inside smart contracts and you
can do some intelligent things with it
so it has a lot going for this store of
value what's difficult about it is it's
not really private it doesn't
although there are parts of it that are
private it's not completely private and
it's untrusted it's brand new
as far as stores of value go it's only
from 2009
and so people don't know if it'll be
around forever and how dependent is on
the internet and people aren't really
certain about
it's not like the proof-of-work mining
algorithm that makes it possible and can
it be hijacked can it be centralized can
it have a bug can it break
and every year that bitcoin survives and
goes through one of the various
challenges facing it it gets more
valuable as people entrust it a little
bit more and more
but it is extremely volatile you buy
bitcoin you're buying a very speculative
asset at the moment and you're
speculating that it will become digital
gold or possibly even
you know all store value and so be
incredibly valuable but along the way
there's lots of hiccups at any point
it could break it could go to zero and
so
a lot of people who are now
participating in the crypto world
they're building a decentralized wall
street they call it d5
d-e-f-i for decentralized finance but i
actually think it's more like
defies and just defy the government defy
and so i think we're seeing yeah
governments love that yeah exactly
we're seeing a whole new casino that's
better than wall street spring
spring up and decentralized finance
unlike wall street this one is 24 7
open it's 365 days a year it's available
around the world
to everybody it's trustless in that it's
you know there's math and algorithms and
code underneath that
not goldman sachs front running your
trades or whatever
not that i'm saying they do but you know
there's flash boys and kind of all that
kind of
craziness that goes on and you can
program it to
do things and to make bets or hedges or
calls that you just can't even do on
wall street so i think we're building a
better wall street using
cryptocurrencies
but everyone who participates in that
doesn't necessarily want to take on the
volatility of these cryptocurrencies
so we've created these things called
stable coins which track the value of
the us dollar
so that when you're trading for example
you can still do it in dollar
denominated terms and this is a tricky
thing because
the moment you're now trying to track
some asset in the real world
like dollars then you have to basically
peg the value somehow to something that
exists in the real world and
cryptocurrencies do best
when everything is on the blockchain
when everything is electronic and
digital and controlled by computers in
the cloud
so these stable coins have come along
that mimic the value of the us dollar
and the best known ones are tether
usdc which is coinbase's coin and uh
uh and uh uh make or die which is an
algorithmically stable coin
but there's no lunch in life for one
second well is this
should people think of what would be a
comparable that people might be more
familiar with it's not an index
it's like an etf or how would you think
about
is there another digital dollars these
are designed so that
you can live in crypto land this is
living on a blockchain it's math-based
code
but really your value is pegged to
dollars so it's not going up or down
with bitcoin it's just
it's just worth a dollar all the time so
if you want to hold a dollar in crypto
land the way you do it is by buying one
of these so-called stable coins
but all my tweet was observing is that
there's no free lunch
the what you're actually doing
underneath is you have crypto and crypto
is incredibly volatile
and you're trying to convert a volatile
asset into a stable asset so there has
to be a cost for that
what is that called like the subprime
mortgage crisis that's right
exactly there's no free lunch so what
does that cost and all i was saying is
that
the three main categories of stable
coins today they each impose one or more
of these costs
and so one cause is fraud risk where
people suspect this of tether where like
actually
this thing says it's backed by dollars
but it's not actually backed by dollars
i don't know if this company is dollars
underneath
so you have to kind of take their word
for it so now you're trust underneath
meaning they would have
actual physical dollars like you would
have physical gold correct
yeah so for every tether they issue you
they claim to have a dollar somewhere
but what if they don't and you just
don't know so you're trusting them and
there could be fraud underneath i'm not
saying there is
i have no evidence but that you're
basically now back to the trusted
third-party model
that exists in just putting your money
in the bank the second kind is where
you're dealing with someone like
coinbase or some company that is well
known and trusted and is regulated
but then it's no different than holding
normal dollars there's censorship risk
where if the government says hey we
don't like this character
seize their bank account coinbase can
turn off your usdc account and your
stablecoin has basically been seized
you're no longer decentralized and
sovereign like you are with bitcoin
and the last kind of risk is a blow-up
risk so something like a maker
you know it's collateralized but it's
collateralized with bitcoin and ethereum
and so what they're hoping is that
the price of bitcoin ethereum won't move
so drastically the peg breaks
and you lose money on your so-called
stablecoin it's just it's just an
observation there's no free lunch
and so if you're trying to create this
this mythical
stable currency out of thin air in what
is inherently very volatile
space you have to pay for it and people
think today they're not paying for it
they're just getting these
uh free crypto stable dollars or they're
getting the stability aspect for free
but they're not they're either taking on
fraud risk or censorship risk or blow up
risk or some combination of them
so if you're advising and this is not
financial advice this is just two
friends talking obviously for
informational purposes only but
if if you're talking to a friend who has
a fair amount of
savings or investable capital and they
say neval
i want to do something with crypto how
can i get started or how should i get
started
what do you say to them because there
there's such a
broad spectrum of options it's still
even though it's been simplified a lot
crypto is still quite confusing it's
very complicated absolutely
for people who are who are who are very
smart i would consider it's still quite
confusing incredibly confusing yeah
it's a domain of mathematicians hackers
you know tech entrepreneurs and
and um a few people who really dig in
but it's still too hard to handle man
it's just dangerous like i can't hold my
own crypto i have to stick it inside
funds and custodians because i'm a known
public figure and it's a bearer asset so
ironically i can't actually
say it's dangerous you don't hold it
because you would be
i'd be yeah exactly it's a better asset
so you know you don't want to bear a
bearer asset you have to put it inside
vaults you know the equivalent of the
goldman sachs in the space
so like they're custodians like
anchorage is you know an amazing one
there's bitco
there's coinbase so there are these
large custodians or coin list
which is a company i helped start um who
can hold on to your crypto assets for
you
but that's not really the point of
crypto the point of crypto is to be your
own bank so if the government is coming
to seize money or if they're printing
lots of it
you can always withdraw your crypto
assets from these organizations and you
can
carry it yourself you can put on your
laptop which is kind of crazy and risky
and hard
you can do it through a hardware wallet
like a ledger or a trezor which are
pretty well-known hardware wallets
where you have a small specific
device that's designed just for carrying
crypto
but you have to understand you're
replacing the banking system you're
literally replacing the government
all the guns and the police that back up
the banking system
you're replacing all that and all the
control that comes with it
so of course it's going to require some
level of sophistication you're literally
building your own swiss bank
so it is it is quite complicated where
to start well i don't i don't like
giving people buy signals
because if you're going to be a good
investor you also have to have your own
conviction because then you'll know when
to sell
if you call me and ask me when to buy
are you going to call me every day and
say should i sell should i sell
no you don't know that they're really
really important
right you have to fundamentally
understand it yourself so i would say
the first thing is go down the crypto
rabbit hole listen to the interview we
do with nick sabo
go online and start reading up on
bitcoin read up on ethereum read up on
the privacy coins like zcash and monero
learn about the different high level
stuff in the crypto space
decide how much exposure that you want
um go buy it at a coin list or a coin
base or or what have you
figure out which custodian you want to
use you know put it somewhere safe
probably in the cloud unless you really
know what you're doing and if you
if you really know what you're doing
then you can use one of the hardware
wallets or one of the offline schemes
make sure that it is protected in case
that you're attacked or kidnapped or
someone comes to your house or steals
your computer you know you have to cover
all those base cases so it's not easy
but you're literally creating
extra sovereign money you're creating
money where you know if you ever have to
flee the country
you know like the jews had to leave
vienna back in the 1930s
you're not like scrambling for gold
you're you're using crypto
you're not if you're living in some
country where they tend to seize all the
money in your bank account
then you have unseasonable money if
you're worried about hyperinflation as
we print too many dollars then you have
a hedge against the
mmt and all the various excuses that
they're going to use to print money
i mean what probably the scariest thing
that happened in 2020 from a financial
perspective is both the republican and
the democratic party
figured out that oh actually we can just
print lots and lots of money
and the u.s has this reserve dollar
that's reserve currency status with a
dollar
where most of our dollars i think
something like 70 are held by foreigners
because the trusted reserve currency of
the world they use it for trading oil
they use it for
settling international transfers they
use it just to kind of hide money they
used to protect money
from their local inflationary
authorities so because of that
when we print a dollar 70 of that
inflation rate effect is
cost is borne by the rest of the world
not borne by us
and so the the us governments kind of
figured this out and we printed six
trillion dollars to fight the
coronavirus
and so now both parties can agree that
they can just print money to get out of
any problem that they're in
a great tweet that i saw was somebody
wrote that now we know what would happen
if aliens were to invade the earth the
fed would just lower interest rates the
fed would cut interest rates
right and so unfortunately that's just
the situation we're in so
they're going to keep doing that until
at some point the
you know the rest of the world throws in
the towel and says you know this dollar
thing is not working for us
and what we rely upon is that the
european euro or the chinese
renimbi and these other currencies are
in worse situations
but that's not necessarily always true
i think there are well-managed
currencies like the swiss franc and the
singaporean dollar
there's also uh hard assets like gold
and crypto and real estate
and even the run up in tech stocks at
some
levels because equities are a tax
efficient inflation hedge or relatively
tax efficient inflation hedge because
someone like google
can just raise prices and they don't
have to hire more people because they're
a monopoly you know they can lay off
half their engineers and the company
will work just fine
so people are realizing this and there's
a flight into hard assets to get away
from inflation
and crypto is one of the few places
where you can really put your money in
and defend against
something like the dollar reserving its
reserve currency status
and these are black swans it's very hard
to talk about black swans because
obviously since the dollar became the
u.s reserve currency it hasn't lost the
status
even when we went off the gold standard
but at the same time
the pound sterling used to be the
reserve currency of the world and it
lost its status at one point
money used to be gold back and that went
away so it's not inconceivable that'll
happen
and if it were to happen then you would
basically have the true reckoning then
our ability to print our
way out of recessions would go away uh
you would probably have an inflationary
collapse in the u.s
and you would just see kind of our our
global economic system start breaking
down
in those scenarios crypto does really
well assuming the internet stays up
right there's scenarios where the
internet goes down too and then all hell
breaks loose and you better have golden
guns but we're not talking about that
um cigarettes and tampons that's great
for your water yeah that's right well
bullets are the ultimate one right as we
as we also see in 2020 but we have 5
million new gun owners in the u.s
but it just depends how much of a
prepper you are how paranoid you want to
be and how many standard deviations out
you want
you want to handle risk but i think this
is the year where a lot of people feel
like risks that were inconceivable have
suddenly gotten pulled in
let me ask a dumb newbie question as a
hypothetical
so speaking as someone who i'm a great
example of someone who can use words
associated with crypto who really has no
fundamental understanding i'm the i'm
the guy pointing at the bird who thinks
he's
got it all figured out because he's able
to name the yellow threaded warbler
i don't think i have it all figured out
but let's just say i managed
somehow like a you know a thousand
monkeys typing out
shakespeare on a million laptops given
infinite time i somehow manage
to get a bunch of cryptocurrency onto
a hardware ledger right or a hardware
wallet rather
so i have this thing us is going to hell
in a handbasket
i somehow manage to get that to
fill in the blank i'll just arbitrarily
choose spain like i land in spain i'm
like oh my god that was so close
thank god i got out in time i managed to
make it over
how the hell do you buy an apartment or
pay your rent or anything like that with
crypto when it still feels like
the crypto landscape and the tools are
kind of computers pre
graphic user interface do you know what
i mean like even smart people can't
quite figure it out
but what would you how would you if that
were
two years in the future i mean i think
that's unlikely but let's just say
uh yeah for most of my friends the
scenario i recommend is like you go buy
it on something like you know coinbase
coin list whatever
you move it into a dedicated custodian
like an anchorage
uh or a bitco um then you kind of hold
it there
now if the [ __ ] is hitting the fan and
you decide you want to get out of town
then you contact your rep there you move
it into a hardware wallet and then you
flee the country right or go wherever
you're going
and when you land on the other side now
you have this crypto in your hardware
wallet
in theory you can log into a local
crypto exchange you know go through
their verification processes and upload
it now you've got
bitcoin that can be traded for cash um
or
you can go find any of the local bitcoin
meetup people and groups
the enthusiasts the so-called maximalist
the die-hard believers and the holders
and you can trade any of them bitcoin
for cash now
in the distant future it's possible that
people will just take bitcoin directly
because it is a
you know fungible high quality hard
asset that can be
transported and held like cash but if
you can't do that you can always find
either a local believer or you can find
a crypto exchange where you can convert
it
the thing that makes bitcoin so
interesting is not that it's necessarily
the best technology it is definitely
robust and it's the og
what makes it really interesting is it
has the most die-hard believers and
because it has the most die-hard
believers as long as there's
five thousand or fifty thousand wealthy
brilliant people who just that the
wealthy part is really important yeah
that wealthy party
they will always trade it for you for
trade it with you for hard assets
uh you know i think recently
microstrategy started
it's a company it started moving half of
its treasury into bitcoin and the ceo
michael saylor was quoted as saying
something along the lines of
i can't believe people willing to sell
me bitcoin right he figured out what it
was
and then he was just like i want to get
as much as possible so you know here
take pieces of my company but give me
bitcoin
and there are there are lots of people
like him there are lots and lots of
people like him and they exist in every
major country in the world
and as long as there are believers
because it's as much a movement or
religion
as it is a currency and because what
what is a currency at the
end of the day money is just the bubble
that never pops
right it's just if we all agree tomorrow
that if we all manage to come upon the
story tomorrow
that it's not the us dollar it's
actually the euro that is really money
then the world will switch to the euro
heck if we agreed that clamshells were
money the you the world would switch to
clam shells now obviously
their underlying characteristics that
make euros and dollars better than
clamshells and so therefore we converge
upon those
but if the world were to decide that
bitcoin is better money than us dollars
the world would switch to bitcoin it's a
story it's a consensus belief
and the beauty of bitcoin is that there
are these die-hard maximalists and i
fight with them on the internet all the
time they don't like me by the way
so i've had twitter battles with them
running but i still
really appreciate that they exist
because they are
actually the core of what makes bitcoin
always tradeable always valuable there's
always some guy
in some location somewhere in the world
who will give you his house for bitcoin
and as long as that is true and i don't
see why it will stop being true because
if anything more and more people are
being added to that list every day
it has real value and has redeemable
value
what do you think the conceivable
near term looks like with
the possible entrance of more
institutional
investors in other words if we see
let me ask a better question it was very
noteworthy and newsworthy when paul
trudeau jones
wrote his memo detailing why he was
investing i think it was something like
100 million
into bitcoin or bitcoin like
equivalence some type of crypto
equivalent
uh if not crypto itself do you
anticipate that
more institutionals are going to come in
sovereign wealth funds things like that
and
how do you think the the story and the
landscape
could change over the next handful of
years i think it's inevitable
look bitcoin and crypto still have risks
right a lot of these
algorithms and schemes are new even
bitcoin through this proof-of-work
mechanism you could argue that it
tends towards centralization because it
gets managed by these anonymous miners
and data centers and data centers of
economies of scale
and so it will end up being more
centralized than people would like
um there are up-and-coming competitors
like ethereum there's privacy issues you
know on the bitcoin blockchain you can
be tracked forever
so it's not perfect you know people talk
about quantum computing breaking it i
don't think that's true
i think you can upgrade the encryption
algorithm you know just as well or
better
but there are always potential problems
right which are not completely resolved
but every time we face one of these
reckonings and
that problem gets resolved the value
goes up the story becomes stronger
and so the same way when paul tudor
jones or microstrategy by bitcoin the
story is becoming stronger
the set of believers is increasing the
validation is increasing and now more
people can come in and hang their hat on
this and say
okay if paul tudor jones agrees and
michael saylor agrees then i agree to be
in that set of people who believe that
this is going to be the new
way to store value and wealth and so now
i'm joining their wealth storage scheme
and the early people then get rewarded
for it so one way to think about
a bitcoin in particular is or even
actually any of the cryptocurrencies is
it's a swiss bank account
but it's a swiss bank account with
finite space and if you want
shelf space in that swiss bank account
with finite space
you have to buy out one of the existing
holders in that space
so imagine a swiss bank count that's
impregnable it's a new one
no government can break into it it's
secured by consensus
across millions of people using massive
computation power on the globe
and if you want one of those safety
deposit box
you got to buy it from someone who's
already there
so as long as the demand for new people
trying to get in the swiss bank account
is greater than the supply of people who
are trying to get out of that swiss bank
account
then you're going to pay more for that
box and that's where the speculative
power of it comes from
and i think it's going to take a good
crisis to really see
what crypto is worth and actually so far
it's been weird because
yeah the people's people have said that
crypto failed the crisis test
with covet right i mean it didn't didn't
what it didn't do was it didn't
skyrocket
right it didn't like go you know bitcoin
didn't go to 100k
as everybody fled the us dollar but that
kind of shows you how resilient the
dollar is and how far we are from losing
global reserve currency status
but at the same time it didn't collapse
either you know it didn't go down it
went down briefly as people needed cash
to meet various margin calls and loans
but overall stayed very stable
and i would say the number of people who
have gotten involved in crypto recently
as a true wealth protection mechanism is
the largest i've ever seen
so i do think that the holder base has
gone up i don't know if we're going to
see like real
you know 3 000 bitcoin ever again in my
lifetime we might see
zero if something breaks completely but
i don't think we're going to see like a
you know a bunch of people leaving and
losing faith in it and that's why it
goes to 3k
bitcoin tends to hit these highs then
crash back down to a plateau hang out in
a plateau for a while and then go back
to a new high and i kind of feel like
we're
you know around the 10k level who knows
i don't want to make price predictions
but
you know i feel like there's a stronger
base of holders now than there's ever
been
so each one of these people comes and
validates it you know paul tudor jones
validates it for other hedge fund
managers hedge fund managers validated
for sovereign wealth funds
sovereign wealth funds uh you know
validated for central banks
uh eventually some country out there is
going to say actually
we inflated our currency too much our
currency collapsed nobody trusts us
anymore
we have to adopt a new national currency
instead of pegging to the dollar let's
peg the bitcoin or let's use bitcoin or
let's use some other cryptocurrency
or let's be clever and buy up a bunch of
bitcoin and then announce we're going to
use bitcoin and then bitcoin will
skyrocket and we're all rich right
so i think there are other scenarios
where it ends up being a lot more
valuable but it's going to be
stumbling steps forward and backward
it's not going to be like necessarily
you know in one fell swoop until it is
right that's the nature of black swans
you can't predict them
when it happens it happens suddenly like
i had a friend who used to tell me he's
now a hardcore bitcoin it's funny he
actually helped write a book on bitcoin
now but when i first talked about
bitcoin years and years ago
he said what's the big deal he's like if
i ever have to flee the country
you know i'll just buy bitcoin then and
i said yeah when you have to flee the
country
your entire fortune's going to buy you
one bitcoin right that's the problem
it's supply and demand so you can't so
it's like anything else a store of value
it's a hedge
you can't wait till the last second and
i do think more and more smart people
are coming into it every single day
and i think the psychological
dynamics of crypto volatility are a lot
like
casino slot machine right this this
variable reward with high variability
where you just see things spiking and
dropping and then they stay flat and
then they spike and they drop
in a way that is unlike most equities
that you or i would buy on the public
even wall street at some level is a big
casino with a potential positive
expected value and creating some
value for society in terms of hedging
and liquidity for
companies raising money and so on uh and
crypto's doing the same thing it's it's
a global 24 7 365 casino where anybody
in the world can play
but through decentralized finance
underneath you're actually making loans
you're protecting wealth you're storing
it
you're letting people you know buy
derivatives you're letting people hedge
um so all of these things are coming up
like we now have insurance in the crypto
markets we now have
lending in the crypto markets we have
shorting in the crypto markets
uh you know we have computation going on
that requires crypto underneath
look if two computers are talking to
each other if two mini ais
are talking to each other and high speed
uh exchanging resources to run a company
how are they gonna exchange money you
think they're gonna send us dollars
through paypal or through fedwire hell
no they're going to use crypto
crypto is going to is the native
currency of the internet
of course the internet is going to have
its own currency
you know otherwise like saying like the
internet's going to use email through
the usps
you know u.s postal service techno it's
going to have its own
native on-chain on-wire protocol for
communicating
data and so what cryptocurrencies really
are bitcoin isn't a thing
bitcoin is not like there's a coin
sitting somewhere bitcoin is an entry
you know like
what
yeah it's an entry in a virtual ledger
and that virtual ledger is maintained by
tons of machines running across the
world and what you're doing is you're
communicating value
securely across the internet with no
third parties in the middle validating
that that is the correct
communication it's done by the entire
network at once and you're communicating
and transmitting scarcity and value to
the internet and that's a new thing
what the internet gave us before was
digital abundance i can make copies of
everything and that was a very big idea
i can make one podcast and ship it to
everybody i can make one web page and
ship it to everybody that was a very big
idea
and created huge fortunes and huge
revolutions the same way digital
scarcity is an equally interesting idea
which is i can only have
one of this thing if naval has a bitcoin
then tim ferriss doesn't have that
bitcoin or vice versa
that ability to create scarcity and
transmit scarcity and value through the
internet
is just as important as the ability to
create abundance and transmit that
through the internet
and so the native language of the
internet in communications and protocols
around valuable things and on finance is
going to be in cryptocurrencies it's not
going to be any other any other way
so i want to bring up two more tweets
and then we can bring this this to
uh to a close and put a bow on it
first i just want to mention again and i
very rarely do this but i
am very happy with how this discussion
turned out if people want more of the
history
and the design of cryptocurrency which
is endlessly
fascinating just google nick zabo
s s-z-a-b-o and then if you're
interested in diving into audio
naval and i spoke with them two tweets
these are both from september
one i'm gonna read just because i agree
with it super strongly and i also
have observed you following this advice
very well which is all self help boils
down
to choose long term over short term i
would modify the tweet to say though
all truly effective self help boils down
to
choose long term over short term uh and
i mean
that is the entire challenge uh which is
long-term thinking gets you long-term
results uh and i've said this a thousand
different ways
in business you want to play long-term
games with long-term people
in your modern life and addictions and
kind of just dealing with the
avalanche of all the the abundance of
things that are thrown at you that
really traps
like video games or a trap there there's
a shadow career that substitutes for
your real career or
you know smoking weed or drinking
alcohol substitutes for like pleasure
through
uh more simple things like sunlight and
walks and porn substitutes for sex and
this just goes on and on i thought you
were saying
walking sunlight and porn i was like
we're talking yeah that sounds about the
trifecta but look at the
so the related tweet i had is the modern
devil is cheap dopamine
and some interesting people on twitter
point out to me actually the ancient
devil is cheap dopamine as well
and but in modern times we've just hyper
hyper
uh accelerated it you know the modern
mind is over stimulated the modern body
is under stimulated we've just taken all
the creature comforts we've maximized
them to a thousand times
and so literally all success in life
boils down to
a variation in the marshmallow test
where you know can the kid like hold off
and eating the marshmallow for 15
minutes
exchange they get two marshmallows and
the claim is that turned out to be a big
predictor for future success although
like many psych experiments i don't
think it replicates well
um but anyway so it just boils down to
long-term versus short-term
and if you can just adopt long-term
thinking in your mindset you're just
going to have a much easier life
or as our favorite trainer jersey
gregorick says hard choices easy
life easy choices hard life that's it
right so
just can you take a long-term view on
anything compound interest
applies everywhere it applies in
relationships it applies in money it
applies in health and fitness
can you change your habits to
read the kinds of books that you think
will serve you best in the long term the
foundational books
can you change your eating habits so
that you're eating healthy food as
opposed to unhealthy food
can you create an exercise routine that
you can do every day
or every other day so that it's a
consistent part of your life
and so i think a lot of it boils down to
just choosing the long term or the short
term and all the hacks the good hacks
basically help make the long-term choice
palatable or they help
inspire you to kind of keep your eyes
focused on the long term
so an example is if you're doing
something that you love if you're
running a business that you enjoy
it it's probably going to be more fun
than playing a video game if you if you
come home at night from work and your
first instinct is to play a video game
you're suffering at work you're working
just as hard in the video game
but the rewards are all fake because
they're going to change the rules on you
or some 13 year old kid on the internet
will destroy you
because they play that video game all
day long and i used to be a hardcore
video gamer i had a lot of fun doing it
and i did learn
playing games for sure but you know at
this point this age i pick up a video
game
i'm doing it to get away from suffering
and i'm not really getting anything out
of it i could play the video game of
investing
or i could play the video game of
starting companies or i could play the
video game of you know go and play
tennis and that would be good for my
health
so it's good to find so so i think a lot
of it is about finding
the thing that you can do that is fun
for you that looks like
play that feels like play to you but
looks like work to others
that you can do that sustains you for
the long term so for example in foods
what you want to find
is you want to find what is the health
food out there that other people
consider healthy and as nutritionally
healthy profile but that i find tasty
because if i can create those foods if i
can become a good cook
and create great foods that i enjoy
eating and i'll like them
and i can eat them regularly but they're
actually super healthy
that's amazing that's a hack now now i'm
eating for the long term but i'm not
giving up too much of the short-term
pleasure
the same way being in a good
relationship is you know is going to be
watching porn and having a good career
or working enjoyable job or hacking on
some code that i enjoy
is going to be far more productive than
playing a video game i don't want to
sound
preachy but i will just say that as i my
love for reading
came from another one of my tweets is
read what you love until you love to
read
so just fall in love with the idea of
reading itself so it's okay to read the
junk food stuff
just fall in love with reading and
eventually get bored of the simple stuff
and you'll go to the more interesting
stuff
and i love to read enough that i don't
like watching tv
i don't watch movies you know people
start talking about shows that they're
watching on netflix or what have you and
i give them this
empty look i don't watch shows on
netflix they're not interesting it's far
more interesting to me to go for a walk
and be meditative
and i'll be in a very happy place or to
read a book which will be intellectually
stimulating and sure once in a while
watch a movie with friends
or with my wife but it's a social thing
you know i'm doing it as a way of kind
of
sort of being on the same common ground
as them i'm not i would never watch a
movie on my own
unless maybe i was trapped in like a
15-hour airplane flight i was really
bored and i run out of everything else
to do and i just want to zone out
even then i don't think i watch a movie
anymore so i just feel like a lot of it
is like
finding the hacks finding the things
that
make the long term feel effortless to
you and then you win
okay last last question first a
recommendation if you ever do decide to
watch something sorry before we finish
that topic
very important on people find the people
that doesn't take work to be around
the best relationships don't feel like
work you make the other person happy
being yourself they make
you happy by being themselves everyone's
honest no one's putting on an act they
can't carry on for the next decade
same thing with friendships you know the
best friendships or friendships that
were formed or nothing it's not because
you went to school
it's not because you studied on the same
things not because you're working
together it's not because you enjoy
rugby or
or whatever it's because your chemistry
matches your temperament is
similar and so you can be friends with
this person for 30 years 50 years
so the compound interest and
relationships part ironically means
that the best relationships whether
friendships or family
or love are the ones where you don't
have to work too hard at them so you
don't have to sustain
that workload for the rest of your life
and you can do it effortlessly
yeah totally well one of the one of your
quotes that i think of
often and i might be paraphrasing this
is if you want to avoid conflict
rule number one is avoid people who are
constantly involved with conflict
right i mean something along those lines
i mean for example when you're in a
relationship just watch how the other
person treats their worst enemy because
eventually they'll just redefine you as
enemy
and you'll get to feel that behavior so
i think the number one
criteria i look for in a in a
relationship is that a person has to be
kind
they just have to be a nice person and
because eventually they'll
in a certain context you can always be
reclassified from friend to enemy
so you just want to see the boundaries
of someone's ethics if you see someone
being bad to a server or someone
engaging in unethical behavior or suing
other people or fighting other people
all the time
it's only a matter of time before they
fight you so just stay away from these
high conflict people
everyone has conflict no one is clean
but that said
like there are definitely people who
engage in conflict and do it regularly
and they make it a part of their
lifestyle
just walk away it's not worth it there's
plenty of
people who are low conflict and easy to
get along with yeah low conflict low
maintenance
who can also be brutally candid when
necessary right which doesn't equal
eye conflict well the one thing i've
noticed and i haven't written the tweet
on this because i've
had a hard time figuring how to say it
but the people that i want to spend time
around
these days when i look at what the
common characteristic is
they're highly self-aware they're very
very aware of themselves they're not
running on autopilot
they don't get angry easily they don't
get unhappy easily
they don't take themselves too seriously
they have a certain separation from
their own thoughts and personality
that prevents circumstances and their
personality from overwhelming them
they don't have a victim mentality
they're not caught up in some story of
what happened to them when they were
younger
they've had those issues for sure but
they've just gotten past them and been
like
i don't want to be that person i don't
be trapped in that mindset
they're not trying to signal all the
time how important they are or who they
know
or what they've done or how virtuous how
virtuous they are they're not virtue
signaling or bigoteering they have low
egos
generally i can literally plot on a line
the more self-aware somebody is i
guarantee you the more attractive that
they are to a large
number of people and to into the degree
that i've achieved
any modicum of fame and fame is a trap
and i'm going to pay for this
i know i will pay for this but any
modicum of fame that i've achieved
i think is because i am one of the few
people
who has been successful in business that
thinks out loud in public
and because i'm willing to think out
loud in public that's a risk that i take
on
it improves my thinking but other people
say oh yeah he's somewhat self-aware
he's thinking about
himself and i think that helps inspire
other people to also say okay it's okay
for me to think about myself
and i just i just find hanging around
self-aware people is a lot easier than
people who are running on autopilot
almost like npcs
npcs what does that mean non-player
characters
it's a reference to certain kinds of
video games where it's like a
computer control character right they're
predicted all right so speaking of games
this
is this is the the final tweet the final
podcast
here it is the reason to win the game is
so that you can be free of it
and my questions about this are wait one
more time the reason to win the game is
so that you can be free of it
i would be curious to know what game
you are free of or what game you are
playing so that you can be free of it
i like to think i'm free of almost all
the games at this point
what are the games all of life is games
right you start out with the
family game you do the school game the
grades game
the getting girlfriends and boyfriends
game the getting married game the having
kids game the
the making money game they're having the
career game the getting famous game
the dressing well game you know it's so
much of a social games
there are a few that are not games like
meditation you're not doing if you're
scoring points in meditation you're
doing it wrong
yoga these are single-player games right
so it's really the multiplayer games are
the ones that suck you into society and
into
anxiety now you kind of have to play
them you have two choices towards peace
in your life one is you can play these
games and you can win them
and when you win them this is the hard
part realizing you've won
and stopped playing new ones or setting
new goals for yourself that are even
higher and higher it's like my friends
who have made so much money
and they continue all they try to do is
make money and they just don't seem very
happy about it it's fine if they're
happy if they're
like elon musk seems like he's having a
grand old time
that's fine but if it's making you
miserable and you continue doing it and
you only have one life and you kind of
can't see past that then
i would argue you're playing the game
too far so there's kind of two ways out
of the trap
one is not wanting something is as good
as having it
right i think it was lyad shabo said
this on twitter i thought it was really
good
or there's a recent socrates quote that
i retweeted where
he was taken to uh the story is he was
taken to a a market
back in ancient greece and it was full
of luxurious and fine items
and he said there are so many things
that i do not want
right and it was he looked at all these
finders and said so many things here
that i do not want
and i thought that is freedom that is
power that is self-contained
uh that is a person who has found
himself and needs nothing outside of
himself that is so inspirational
so the same way i look upon the world
and i say well i could just say that
right you can't just say that if i just
said
there's so many things that i don't want
it's not true i want the money
i want the girl you know i want i wanted
the fame or i wouldn't have gone on
podcast and i wouldn't be on twitter at
some level that is true
so obviously there's certain things that
i want i'm not a monk
i'm not a i'm not living in an ashram
but
what i can do is i've gotten the things
that i want and i'm careful
not to want more i don't want more fame
i don't want more money
or if i get it it's fine it's part of
the crafts by the bonus you know
so i have to be careful about what i
about not unconsciously taking on new
desires if i'm taking a new desire
i better go fulfill that so these are
all just games that i'm playing
and you know you got to play some game
you're on this planet you're alive you
might as well play something
now the question is what game do you
play and how do you get out of the game
so you're not just trapped playing that
game
forever and one way is you choose your
games very carefully if you're a monk
you only choose very very few games to
play or you play no games and you live
content
blissful harmonious peaceful or the
other is
you play the game and you win it and
then you say
i am now free of this so what that tweet
is that tweet is
the reason to play the game so the
reason to win the game is to be free of
it
it's a reminder to myself that for the
games that i've won
it's time to let go of them and to be
free of them and not to unconsciously
double down
by comparing myself to the joneses and
continuing to level up and level up and
level up and level up and then one day
you die
and then you're like okay that was
pointless like you know i i did all that
work for what
like for nothing so if you're not
enjoying it anymore if you've already
won the game by the definition you had
when you started playing the game
and one hack is to set the definition
early on so that when you go past it you
know you won
to not get trapped into playing this
game forever
and just living in some anxious future
as opposed to actually enjoying yourself
in the present
you have to know when to stop playing
the game and so to me the reason to play
these games
is to win them and then you can be free
of them
and to see what else then that you want
to do or not do
not to keep playing the same game
forever because these games are
the adult games are very cleverly
designed you can keep playing them
infinitely
and they're all ups and downs and ups
and downs and i guarantee you every time
you get money you'll be afraid you're
going to lose it or you're going to
compare it to the next person who has it
or every time you get famous now that's
uh let's say that's the image that you
have to live up to
and now insults can hurt you and now you
don't have your privacy anymore as
you've written about
so all of these games have downsides or
if you're uh you know
very you're good at dating you have a
lot of men or women in your life then
you're also going to have a lot of
relationship trauma and you've got a lot
of tumultuousness you know a lot of hurt
people you got a lot of emotional drama
in your life
so you just have to kind of realize when
you won the game and say
i'm done with this so i would i would
aspire to be like socrates and say
there are so many things in this world
that i do not want and i like to think
that i'm kind of
there for the most part either i don't
want it or i have it
now of course there's a fear of losing
it which is always there
but i don't want to pick up new desires
unconsciously and i don't want to keep
upgrading my lifestyle and my
expectations to match my circumstances
otherwise i'll be on this treadmill
forever
we are all playing games and the key
is knowing which game you are playing so
you can at least
attempt to consciously choose the game
finite and infinite games by james
carso's
an interesting read and i just want to
close with and then you're certainly
more than
welcome to add any closing comments but
a quote that really
makes me think of you it's one of my
favorite quotes from fineman so richard
p
fineman once again here's the quote the
first principle is that you must not
fool yourself
and you are the easiest person to fool i
love that quote
i love that quote i i read it when i was
9 or 10 years old and i've never
forgotten it
it is so important and none of us are
perfect we all have flaws we all have
weaknesses we all have vices
or i'll speak for myself certainly
that's true of me but
unival as much as anyone else perhaps
more than anyone else i know have gone
to
great lengths to become
self-aware furthermore and this is i
think that
one of the distinguishing
characteristics for me that you
represent
becoming self-aware and spending time on
the timeless
while also reserving the right with
competency to be a very high level
operator in the real world
right because you can be not of this
world by
opting out completely and go into a
world of introspection but in truth lack
the resilience
and emotional awareness to interact with
any type of real stressor
which doesn't appeal to me certainly and
you can be so
engulfed by being in the world
that you lose self-awareness you stop
realizing
that you are playing certain games you
become addicted
and self-identified with
things that come from sort of consensus
reality
that's also not appealing but you have
managed in a way that i find fascinating
to combine the cultivation of
self-awareness with
operating in the world at a high level i
wouldn't say i'm necessarily there yet
but it gets a little easier every year
like yeah the finding quote is is a
brilliant one he's right you we fool
ourselves all the time and i still fool
myself all the time because i still have
strong beliefs and opinions
for example even though i don't tweet a
lot about politics i do have strong
political opinions
um and that is a form of fooling myself
because you know politics is a man-made
game it doesn't really exist in the real
world there's no
no tree is aware of politics and i do
even though i don't like to even some of
my beliefs are filtered and lined up in
bundles based on my
chosen media sources and whatnot so i
fool myself all the time but just if you
can fool yourself a little
bit less then you can navigate reality
much better it doesn't take a lot most
people are just living very
unconsciously you know under
unexamined life so it just gives you
kind of a leg up and i agree with you in
that
you can always like check out of the
game and it's easier that way but then
you're fragile
right you kind of build resilience by
working out hard
and it's hard to be calm until you've
lost a lot
and won a lot like you have to see the
ups and the downs and the ups and the
downs
before you get tired of the dopamine
chase and you sort of realize like okay
this is down but eventually there'll be
an up or there's an op that'll be a down
i know how this game works
so one of the things i've been tracking
recently is i've been trying to
kind of make a a list of what are the
activities that are sort of non-dual in
nature they don't create their own
opposite down the road
so chasing money does create anxiety and
suffering down the road as you compare
and you win and lose and so on
uh you know chasing fame also has
downsides where you can you're not open
to insult and attacks and being
cancelled and what not
so what activities are intrinsically
true
in and of themselves and are kind of are
a free lunch
and so those include things like
meditation yoga
creating art playing reading for fun not
necessarily for knowledge or education
writing journaling you can even be
building a business as long as you're
doing it for the craft of it for the
flow of it
not necessarily for a given outcome
although it's hard to do that
at least externally it seems like elon
musk is doing that he's you know
building rockets to get to mars not to
make money
um or to be famous although he's doing
the he's getting those the byproducts
so i i think that kind of this whole not
fooling yourself
uh paying attention to yourself not
taking yourself too seriously
uh examining your own thoughts from
first principles
um and kind of uh doing activities that
are drawn intrinsically for you
as opposed to for the external world
they just make your life better
i'm not doing these things to be a stoic
sage right honestly
one of the downsides of the stoics is
they don't look like they're having a
lot of fun i still like that
right now obviously loss has been a lot
in translation i know they had their
vomitoriums and they had their orgies
and whatnots
uh but you know the stoics just at least
the way it's a modern projected and this
is one of the reasons why i do like osho
you know people give osho a lot of flack
and they should he he was a little crazy
in some ways but
he was having fun he had a good time
and you know you're alive you got you
have one
very short life when it when your life
ends it goes to zero
it's to you it's indistinguishable from
your perspective
your death is indistinguishable from the
end of the world as far as you're
concerned the world has disappeared
because when you came into existence the
world appeared
when you go out of existence the world
disappears and
that is so consequential that it makes
the rest of your life
inconsequential and that is a form of
freedom and so you should enjoy yourself
you should not suffer in this life if
you are just constantly suffering then
figure out how to get out of that
suffering
if you can't get out of that suffering
then figure out how to redefine your
internal worldview
so that you don't necessarily view it as
suffering any more than the extent that
you need to to get out of it
these days we borrow a lot of suffering
on behalf of other people
a lot of people want to be a little
christ carrying crosses for others
it's a miserable existence you're
actually not doing them any favors
either
you carrying their cross isn't making
their life any better the better way is
for you to be happy
and successful and healthy and then go
save them like literally save them
physically
not necessarily just you know sit around
suffering for them
or at least that's the life that i
choose to live i'm gonna i'm gonna end
with one story
um there was a guy that i met in
thailand uh
craig i forget his last name but he used
to work for tony robbins
and i met this guy and we were on
vacation in thailand
and he was just the happiest person he
was just happy all the time
and he just seemed to be able to laugh
it off and as far as he had a good life
he had stuff going for him but it wasn't
like you know he had this incredibly
enviable life where you would drop
everything
and move to thailand and adopt his
lifestyle he had an okay life
but he was just happy and not in a
forced way but he was genuinely happy
and so i asked him i said like
you know what's your secret why not and
he said that you know he used to work
for tony robbins and used to fly around
setting up events for tony and you know
he was always sitting in the front row
and taking notes and setting things up
and learning and listening and
he just kind of started seeing through
his own internal bs
he got to this point where like you said
like he was he was fooling himself into
unhappiness
and he just decided one day he said you
know what i have no responsibility to
anybody in this world
other than me and like or if i do have a
responsibility this kind of weight of
responsibility that goes on where we're
like oh i need to live up to some
imagined self what he realized was he
said somebody in this world
somebody has to be happy all the time
that is somebody's job to be that role
model
for people in the world that might as
well be me i'll be that guy
i'll take on that burden and he decided
to be the happy one and i just thought
that was
simple and brilliant and he did it he
lived there
so you know i want to be that guy who is
successful peaceful happy enjoying life
blissful meditative spiritual successful
and you know as healthy as i can be and
famous
and rich and not give a damn about any
of it so if i lose it all tomorrow
i still want to be happy that's it
that's where i want to be
and i'll just make that decision because
somebody has to be that person
it might as well be me i love it man
uh naval ravikant otherwise known aka
novel
ravakant but naval ravicon naval on
twitter
n-a-v-a-l and he has
the podcast of course naval n-a-v-a-l
you can find that anywhere you find your
podcast the blog
nav.al previous conversations we've had
and we've had quite a few you can just
search naval on the website tim dot blog
forward slash
naval anything else you would like to
add any
other resources places people can say
hello on the internet
recommendations asks of the audience
them all uh i'm mostly on twitter
uh eric jorgensen recently put out a
book which had a bunch of my sayings
called the almanac of naval ravicon it
was very nice of him
i don't make any money off of it it's
free on the internet you can just
download it i think it never almanac
clever little turn of phrase yeah i
think i think that's it
we'll see you on the interwebs you know
i i wish everybody has a
wealthy healthy and happy life like go
get it
thanks so much neval for taking the time
this is awesome and uh to everybody
listening
thank you for tuning in and until next
time don't fool yourself
sit down spend some time with your mind
and uh don't be too hard
on that roommate in your head
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little more soul of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just
a little tiny bite of goodness before
you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
ship station the holiday season is fast
approaching and we know that people will
be buying more stuff online than ever
before
all of these trends to ecommerce have
been accelerated due to covet and much
more
if you're an e-commerce seller are you
ready to meet the demands of
record-breaking online shopping season
be ready with shipstation
shipstation.com is the fastest
easiest and most affordable way to
manage and ship your orders
in just a few clicks you're managing
orders printing out discounted shipping
labels and getting your products out
fast happier holidays for you and your
customers
shipstation takes the hassle out of
holiday shipping no matter where you're
selling
on amazon etsy your website via shopify
or other platforms
shipstation brings all of your orders
into one simple
interface and shipstation works with all
of the major carriers usps
fedex ups even international you can
compare and choose the best shipping
solution every time
and you can access the same postage
discounts that are usually reserved
for large fortune 500 companies it's no
wonder that shipstation is the number
one choice of online sellers
and right now my listeners that's you
guys can try shipstation free
for 60 days when you use offer code tim
just go to the homepage shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage
and type in tim tim that's it go to
shipstation.com then enter offer good
tim shipstation.com
make chip happen this episode is brought
to you by
tonal t-o-n-a-l i'm super excited about
this one
and i was skeptical of it in the
beginning total
quote tonal is the world's most
intelligent home gym and personal
trainer end quote that's the tagline
from their website folks to give you the
one sentence summary and
this device it's really a system is
perfect for anyone looking to take their
home workouts to the next level or
someone who just wants to get maximum
bang for the buck
in a tiny tiny footprint of space
tonal is precision engineered to be the
world's most advanced strength studio
and personal trainer it uses
breakthrough technology of all different
types
to help get you stronger faster i was
introduced to total by three different
friends
all of them are tech savvy one of them
is a former competitive skier
who's doubled his strength at a number
of movements using tonal even though
he has a long athletic background
and i'll paint a picture for you by
eliminating traditional metal weights
dumbbells and barbells tonal can deliver
200 pounds of resistance which doesn't
sound like a lot but it's actually
it feels like a lot more at the high end
in a device smaller than a flat screen
tv and you can perform at least 150
different exercises and these different
technologies are exclusive to total and
you can dial weights
up and down with the touch of a button
in one pound increments
using magnets and electricity so the
movement is extremely smooth
and even though i have a home gym
already in my garage
i'm still getting a tonal installed i've
used
tonal for multiple workouts now to do
things i just cannot do
in my home gym such as the chop and lift
exercises from the 4-hour body all sorts
of cable exercises that would usually
involve much much bigger piece of
equipment eccentric
training for instance you can do to give
a simple example
bicep curls where you are lifting let's
just say
20 pounds in each hand up and then total
will automatically
increase the weight because you can
lower more than you can lift
to say 25 or 30 pounds on the way down
and i do
kettlebell swings i do all sorts of
deadlifts this that the other thing and
after one workout
on tonal focusing on pulling i was
blasted for a full
week it's really incredible what you can
do with eccentrics
they also have all sorts of other really
really cool advantages that you can
apply to any of your
favorite movements tonal learns from
your strength and provides suggested
weight recommendations for every move
detailed progress reports to help you
see your strengths grow
total also has a growing library of
expert lead workouts by motivating
coaches from strength training
to cardio so you can do really just
about everything every program is
personalized to your body
using artificial intelligence and other
aspects
of the engineering and smart features
check your form in real time just like a
personal trainer
so try it out try tonal at least check
it out watch
the videos on youtube and see if you can
pick out a familiar voice
it's not me i'll say that but try tonal
the world's smartest home gym
for 30 days in your home and if you
don't love it you can return it for a
full refund so visit
www.tonal.com for 100
off of smart accessories when you use
promo code tim
tim at checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim tonal be your strongest